I have some of the most entertaining
video in a while from I would say from
the world of politics generally and that
says a lot because it's 2018 and Donald
Trump is President of the United States
when they were in Argentina for the g20
summit just a few days ago Donald Trump
and Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau and Mexican president Enrique
Pena Nieto signed a new trade agreement
during this trip and the entire thing
was just a complete and utter fiasco
which culminated with Donald Trump
signing the deal in the wrong place and
what I mean by that is Trump wasn't in
the wrong room
he wasn't in the wrong building he
didn't sign it in a country where he
didn't have jurisdiction that's not what
I mean I mean that he literally seemed
unsure where on the piece of paper he
should sign his name and the other world
leaders around him were visibly confused
as were the aides and other people
standing behind them so let me kind of
work up to that because there's a lot
here the first thing that happened which
I just love is that Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau referred to
Trump as Donald during the press
conference about this signing which
Donald Trump just hates and you're gonna
see Donald Trump visibly displeased by
this and Donald it's all the more reason
why we need to keep working to remove
the tariffs on steel and aluminum
between our countries yeah so we're
already off to a very bad start but then
we really get to the good part and I
know that this is a very visual segment
because we have audio podcast and radio
listeners I always consider is this
segment too visual for the people that
are just listening this is one of those
instances and I apologize for that our
our audio audience is not going to be
able to grasp the full insanity of this
without finding the clip online so I'll
describe to you what we're about to see
Donald Trump starts signing the three
copies of this deal incorrectly and
everyone else Trudeau the Mexican
president the dignitaries standing
behind them everybody looks
extremely confused and sort of wondering
like okay he doesn't know how to sign it
he doesn't know how to sign his name
what do we do do we say anything you
know you're gonna see here people
visibly trying to hold and laughter I
would get the kids out of the room
because of the cringe here Trump starts
looking around and immediately you can
see that the other world leaders are
wondering what is wrong with this guy
look great the look on their faces
which is the winner
extraordinarily bizarre and I'm not
going to subject you to too much more of
this but here's a much shorter focused
inversion where you will actually see
the key moments of just absolute and
total bewilderment from the people
standing around Donald Trump
we'll trade
which is the menthol which is the one
that passed each of us get a cup
[Music]
pat when we say Trump is a laughingstock
around the world it's not a figure of
speech a couple months ago when Trump
spoke at the United Nations General
Assembly the room of world leaders
laughed in his face
when he tried to talk about just how
great everything was how he has the best
presidency of any president in history
he's trying to sign a piece of paper and
other world leaders and dignitaries are
visibly bewildered by what the guy is
doing this goes beyond anything we've
seen before doesn't it yeah I love that
video I like how at the very beginning
of it he's looking over at the other
documents as if he's cheating on a test
like what you get for question number
four type thing and also the pun
enthusiast in me loved when he goes
we'll trade I like that one too oh yes
because it was a traitor I didn't even
notice that that went completely over my
head actually and I would probably bet
that it was not deliberate by Trump I
think the guy is not capable of that
kind of pun what is it it's not pundit
tree it's pun hunt punny
Panetta punning yeah but you know
funning he's not cunning nor capable of
punting I think I would say why can't
the guy just sign his name correctly on
contracts and treaties and trade
agreements and I would actually suggest
to you is it possible this is a strategy
like imagine if all along Donald Trump's
strategy and business has been I'm gonna
sign in the wrong place so later if
there's any issue I can say I signed on
the dateline not where my name's
supposed to go the entire contract is
invalid like is that is that something
Trump could be cunning enough to carry
off or is it just an accident maybe
that's how he gets away with not paying
the people he hires and also his
signature kind of looks like a
cardiogram like it's very up-and-down so
I think people could look at that and
say that that's not someone signing
their name what it what the hell is that
a lot of problems with Donald Trump's
signature more problems with Trump's
signature than any any president I can
remember bizarre video really the video
should be overlaid with the curvier
Enthusiasm theme that's actually how the
video would make that that would be the
natural environment for that video check
it out send me your thoughts if you're
just listen
here's a really interesting little clip
by the way from the right-wing media
machine around the Trump investigation
this is from Fox News yesterday even on
Fox News now
anchors are starting to concede that you
know what robert molars Trump rushman
investigation might actually have
something and before I play the clip
it's really important just to preface it
by reminding you about the goalposts
moving that's taken place right early on
Fox News was fully on the there's
nothing to investigate and no big
investigation is going to take place
that was the first position Fox took the
investigation started
they were then on the there's nothing to
find
there's no collusion this will go
nowhere and not last very long bandwagon
then they move the goalposts to okay if
there was collusion what crime is that
anyway that's not a specific crime then
they move to well okay there might
actually be some ancillary incidental
criminality by people loosely in Trump
circle but it's not going to have
anything to do with the real heart of
trumps campaign it'll be little
technicalities committed by people prior
to the campaign that wouldn't even be on
the radar of law enforcement were it not
for the political attack that is the
investigation into Donald Trump and then
we get back to reality and of course in
reality we're heading to sentencing for
Trump's national security adviser we're
heading to sentencing for Donald Trump's
personal lawyer who was directly
involved in the campaign we're heading
to sentencing for Donald Trump's
campaign chairman I'm talking by the way
about Michael Flynn Michael Cohen and
Paul Manafort and then we also have
lurking in the background Roger stone
and Jerome Corsi to Trump operatives
during the campaign who believe they're
going to be indicted and are negotiating
with Robert Muller and it's looking
really really bad it also by the way
appears that Donald Trump's written
answers to Robert Muller might directly
contradict what Michael Cohen a
cooperating witness has said to Robert
Muller that Donald from Junior's test
might directly contradict what michael
cohen told prosecutors so it's getting
really bad and perjury lying under oath
is now on the table for multiple Trump
family members so now we cut to
yesterday even on Fox News they're
starting to admit it check out this clip
where they have this right-wing or match
slap on who continues to insist that
there's just nothing here and one of the
hosts who goes by Kennedy says it's
starting to get a little weird and
Muller might actually have something
there's that but I say something very
quickly put a pin in it Kennedy there
might be something there they're
absolutely might be something there we
don't know what more has he might
something he might have something things
are starting to seem a little weird you
know what else you might have he might
have something on the dossier I hope he
does if they're if they're putting one
aspect of filthy dirty disgusting
politics cavorting with questionable
Russians on one side they have to do it
on the other but there might be
something there we will stay tuned we
will see hopefully soon so you'll notice
that she kind of does the both sides
thing she says okay molar might have
something but he also might have
something on that dirty filthy immoral
dossier more and more of which by the
way is confirmed with every passing week
the other funny thing is that this
obvious and straightforward admission on
Fox News is considered mind-blowing to
their audience everybody and their
mother who can put together a sentence
understands that hey this has been
serious all along
this hasn't been frivolous all along on
Fox News Pat it's almost like oh wow
they're admitting that the entire
investigation might not be a ruse like
there might actually be something here
on Fox News that counts as a monumental
admission there are also like many
conspiratorial elements that statement
to it sounds like the Q on on stuff that
Robert Muller maybe as actually working
with Trump and he's going to end up in
died ting Hillary Clinton in John
Podesta there's no evidence of that but
I think that conspiratorial nature is
becoming part and parcel with the
Republican Party nowadays well let me
propose along those lines one other idea
this isn't conspiratorial but it's sort
of the idea that starting to concede
that this is a real serious
investigation as part of
strategy because we saw rudy guiliani
say a couple of weeks ago I think molars
report will be devastating to Trump
Kennedy saying you know there this could
be bad this could be a strategy to start
painting a really grim picture so that
then when molars report finally does
come out they all go oh this is all they
had we've been saying for so long now
that it's going to be really bad but
this is all they had give me a break
one other note later in the segment that
matched lap guy said molar has no case
and that all molar is doing his quote
taking the dirt he's gotten on people
like Cohen and squeezing them to get
everything he can out of them that's
what an investigation is that's what law
enforcement does they talk to witnesses
they learn more about what people did
and they figure out who else to talk to
and who might have committed crimes like
mad slap defends Trump by just saying
what an investigation is apparently on
Fox News that counts as a serious legal
defense of the president and an
indictment of the investigation they're
talking to witnesses and using the
information they get to make deductions
and find more people to talk to send me
your thoughts the show is on instagram
at david pakman show i'm on instagram at
david dot Pakman fall Oh us both lotta
behind-the-scenes pictures viewer
comments a lot of good stuff on there I
was super interested in following the
g20 summit in Argentina over the last
few days in part because this is where I
was born my home city of Buenos Aires
Argentina but also because of the
interesting geopolitical dynamics that
have emerged recently and sort of seeing
how they would play out we saw this very
strange moment of Vladimir Putin and the
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
high-fiving and hugging and just
genuinely thrilled to see each other of
course all in the context of the killing
of Jamal khashoggi in the context of
both Russia and Saudi Arabia apparently
having Donald Trump in their pocket that
was interesting to see I was interested
in seeing how the relation
ship would reflect what is going on in
terms of tension between European
countries and of the United States of
America also Argentina involved in
financial bailouts with some of these
countries I mean a lot of interesting
stuff going on but near the top of the
list
I was curious to see how would Donald
Trump behave given the insanity of the
last week given the Russia Trump Tower
leaks the Michael Cohen guilty pleas so
much imploding for Trump and Trump did
not disappoint or he did disappoint I
guess depending on your perspective in
an ideal world our president would be a
true ambassador for American values and
ideas around the world they would be
respected by other leaders and countries
we don't have that so the next ideal
situation would be well okay the
president would be someone who even if
not the best ambassador for us would at
least appear to be a professional when
they go to summits around the world
Trump can't do that either so if they're
not going to seem like a professional
ideally a president wouldn't throw a
tantrum and behave like a little kid on
the world stage and sadly that's exactly
what Donald Trump did when I was
watching the introductions and greetings
of each world leader with Argentinean
president Mauricio Macri I noticed that
something really strange happened and we
have video of it where Donald Trump had
a kind of strange exchange with the
president and then started walking away
the Argentinean president seemed
confused and some guy ran across the
camera shot after Donald Trump wasn't
clear who it was and the Argentinean
president seemed uncomfortable to say
the least turned around and I could only
imagine that this could only be more
interesting with the Curb Your
Enthusiasm thing song playing playing
over it I mean it was just a bizarre
bizarre exchange and it was initially
chalked up to a confusion about the
photo-op that was supposed to happen
next however it appears that this was
part of Trump behaving exactly like a
tantrum and kid the entire weekend
because he was recorded just off-camera
saying get me out of here to an aide as
the other leaders were gathering for a
picture here's the audio it's clear but
there is back
growl noise so let's listen to it
together
Trump eventually reappeared and there
are a few angles here to consider so
first of all it's listen
Trump's panicking Trump's freaking out
about what's happening with Russia Saudi
Arabia
he's imploding and his presidency is
imploding in front of him and he just
has no attention span for the g20 and he
wanted to get the hell out of there
that would actually be reasonable I mean
I know when I have lots of things going
on it's tough to really focus on what
has to be done work chores whatever so
that's one possibility the other is that
Trump was upset because of how other
leaders were treating him I mean at this
point Trump is seen as a joke by leaders
around the world the Japanese prime
minister's wife previously pretended not
to understand English to not have to
talk the talk to Trump France and the UK
and Germany increasingly don't even
invite Trump to anything related to
climate change and why would they what's
the point the guy thinks it's a hoax
concocted by China and if increasingly
Trump at these events is feeling left
out he's feeling like they don't care
about what he has to say given his
personality that would also
understandably make him furious and make
him want to leave and it is just one
embarrassment after the other all of the
horrible stereotypes about Americans
around the world that I tried to dispel
when I travel Donald Trump embodies down
to the finest detail I genuinely don't
know why the world even bothers with the
sky and the strongest counterpoint to
all of this that I read is this is
simply the scaling up of Trump's
cognitive decline that would actually be
the most inoffensive explanation because
hey it would just be a medical condition
and that would be far better than what
seemed to be serious personality flaws
that this guy has and a total inability
for self-reflection for introspection
that he has proven time again to be
completely incapable of doing on the
world stage am i misinterpreting what
happened in Argentina send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show so in addition to the cringe by the
way of the former US presidents and
their spouses ignoring Donald Trump
at George HW Bush's funeral I wanted to
vote just like a couple minutes to trump
sleeping at George HW Bush's funeral
when Trump plays golf all the time it's
not embarrassing but when he's golfing
he's not doing policy that's a good
thing because when he does policy he
wrecks the country
maybe we should be glad as we show you
what this looked like that Donald Trump
was sleeping during the funeral of
George HW Bush because when he's
sleeping he's not saying embarrassing
things or doing embarrassing things
maybe that's the upside to all of this
but yes Donald Trump appearing to sleep
through the funeral which is
embarrassing but at least he's not
insulting anybody but there is something
serious here related the trunk that I
want to discuss that sort of came to my
mind in watching his behavior and seeing
how he was treated at George HW Bush's
funeral which is that Trump was de facto
rebuked at the funeral as he should be
his name wasn't mentioned once by
anybody period even though he's the
current President of the United States
we know Trump hates this Trump wants
recognition everything that Trump said
everything that was said rather by
george w bush during his eulogy
indicated that the Trump doctrine the
Trump milieu is the exact opposite of
what George HW Bush sort of worked to
build all of the compliments about
George HW Bush implicitly rebuked Trump
and Dana Millbank had a really good
explainer about this in the Washington
Post thousand points of light kept being
mentioned as as a catchphrase of George
HW Bush Trump made fun of it and at the
funeral it was mentioned time and again
as something positive that George HW
Bush had said george w bush mentioned it
during his eulogy he also mentioned that
when George HW Bush won he shared credit
and when George HW Bush lost he took
responsibility he shouldered the blame
that's the exact opposite of Trump now I
don't know if Trump is clever
or or intelligent enough to realize that
but these are de facto rebukes of Donald
Trump george w bush talked about George
HW Bush's relationship with Bill Clinton
and how it was sort of a Brotherhood
that developed that's not the way things
are developing for Donald Trump with
former presidents senator Alan Simpson
spoke former senator and pointed out
that George HW Bush never hated anyone
that is not something that can be said
about Donald Trump based on his behavior
said that he was loyal to the
institutions of government the exact
opposite of what we've seen from Donald
Trump
now I concede that these de facto
rebukes of Trump are so over his head
Pat that I can't imagine Trump even
understands them as contrasting elements
of George HW Bush to him but to a lot of
the people in the audience it was very
clear yeah he may not he may not
understand him they may go over his head
but he does get annoyed I think that
he's not getting any recognition from
the speakers and essentially the same
thing happened when John McCain passed
away a few months back now Donald Trump
wasn't invited to that funeral because
McCain didn't want him there but many of
the speaker's had these sort of tacit
critiques of the current administration
and you can tell that it works Trump I
think especially so because he actually
had to sit through it this time yeah he
looked miserable sitting there with his
arms crossed and just looking misery
when he wasn't sleeping he looked very
very clearly miserable and one of the
most subtle but brilliant instances of
trolling Trump that took place during
the eulogies yesterday at George HW
Bush's funeral was when the former
Canadian Prime Minister Brian Mulroney
spoke and pointed out that world leaders
knew that when they dealt with George HW
Bush they were dealing with a gentleman
they were dealing with a distinguished
and brave genuine leader that's just
about the furthest opposite you can get
to George HW between George HW Bush and
how Donald Trump is seen by leaders
around the world and we see that Trump
is
child among adults just from how he's
being praised for how he behaved at the
funeral Chelsea Handler tweeted about
this brilliantly where she pointed out
Donald Trump is getting praised for his
behavior at Bush's funeral our president
is such an [ __ ] we have to reward him
when he doesn't make a scene at a
funeral which basically says it all the
standards have become so low the
expectation has become so low of Trump
that he was getting praised on cable
news the other day because he handled
the death of George HW Bush
appropriately that shouldn't even rate
when you evaluate how a president is
doing that they behave after a former
president dies now counts as a point in
favor of Trump because his behavior is
expected to be so atrocious and
ridiculous basically says it all in a
completely kind of random turn of events
Donald Trump the guy who's all about
military spending is now saying that our
military spending is crazy
that's a quote after complaining for so
long about President Obama being weak on
the military about President Obama not
spending enough on the military Donald
Trump tweeted yesterday that too much is
being spent on the military saying quote
I am certain that at some time in the
future President Xi and I together with
President Putin of Russia will start
talking about a meaningful halt to what
has become a major and uncontrollable
arms race the United States spent 716
billion dollars this year crazy now
there's a few layers to this that I want
to talk about the first being that
Donald Trump previously bragged about
how he's spending more on the military
and talked about how great it is that
he's doing that one example from Twitter
Trump saying quote because of the seven
hundred seven hundred and sixteen
billion dollars gotten to rebuild our
military
many jobs are created in our military is
again rich building a great border wall
with drugs poison and enemy combatants
pouring into our country is all about
National Defense build wall through
military one other example from Donald
Trump where he said quote got 1.6
billion to start wall on southern border
rest will be forthcoming most
importantly got 700 billion to rebuild
our military 716 billion next year most
ever had to waste money on dem giveaways
in order to take care of military pay
increase and new equipment Trump
proposed spending 716 billion on the
military in February Trump bragged about
how great it is to be spending 716
billion on the military and now he's
denouncing that we're spending 716
billion on the military so there's a few
hypotheses here number one is cognitive
decline just plain and simple evidence
of cognitive decline number two this is
Trump getting erratic because he's so
afraid as the walls closing around him
based on everything that we've been
talking about on the program leading up
to you today number three hypothesis is
that something happened at the g20 in
Argentina someone at the g20 suggested
to him that he say this or suggested to
him that maybe this is something he
could work on with Putin in the future
like maybe it was Putin himself who said
the Trump you know it's really crazy how
the United States is spending so much
money on the military and then all of a
sudden Donald Trump tweets about it
because it definitely seems like this is
an idea that would come from somebody
like Vladimir Putin Trump criticizing
military budget increases while enacting
and bragging about and cheering military
budget increases Trump increased the
military budget by nearly 25 percent in
two years and now he says that the
military budget is out of control
maybe sort of like a childlike salep
season there's this term object
permanence this is like when a little
kid
covers their eyes they sometimes don't
understand that just because they cover
their eyes and they can no longer see
you you can still see them and this
relates to the psychological concept of
object permanence things still exist
even when you can't see them or you
can't perceive them
it's almost Pat like some deranged adult
version that is manifesting where Trump
says hey I'll just talk about how
military spending is out of control and
nobody will be able to see the fact that
I've been tweeting and bragging about
military spending for the last couple of
years well it certainly doesn't make
sense from a contradiction standpoint
for him to say that but also he's making
it sound as though we're spending 716
billion dollars and Russia and China are
right behind us that they're right in
there with the arms race not at all I
mean we always hear about how the US
spends more than the next eight
countries and defense spending combined
or the next ten countries and defense
spending combined I just I don't really
understand what the impetus was for this
tweet I mean maybe it does have to do
with the g20 but like you could have
said this all along that's what's very
strange about it and it's the timing
that is making me wonder what the hell
is going on and along those lines I have
sort of like one more hypothesis to
present to you which is a little bit
more involved than the ones I've
mentioned so far let's imagine that
Donald Trump realizes that at some point
he's gonna have to make a call about
whether the United States gets involved
in Ukraine or not because as you may
remember Russia's aggression against
Ukraine has been increasing they rammed
a Ukrainian Navy vessel they took and
haven't returned at least as at the last
time that I looked some Ukrainian Navy
sailors almost every other Western
country has come out in defense of
Ukraine if you're Trump and you are
realizing that at some point you might
have to say we're going to get involved
with our allies in defending Ukraine or
we're not what about the possibility of
laying the groundwork
now for saying you know what we can't
afford to get involved to help Ukraine
because we're spending so much on the
military just like I tweeted after the
g20 is that type of forethought possible
for Trump I think so and you know this
is why he takes every possible position
on every possible issue because people
can just pick and choose his comments
well here he said that he wants more
defense spending and here he says he
wants less defense spending so you can
just pick and choose what fits your
political ideology and that's what his
supporters do to be super clear I agree
with Trump that military spending is out
of control I don't want to pretend like
all of a sudden now that Trump says it
it's not what I believe I agree with him
it's just he's almost always tweeting
the opposite of this sentiment and I'm
trying to figure out what is it that's
going on here what do you think is going
on let me know I want to hear from you
okay there's a program called the Reuben
report where people of all political
backgrounds are interviewed mostly
conservatives actually dave rubin as a
cultural critic and interviewer is more
like say Larry King from what I've read
then some other interviewers in that
it's not so much about Dave debating
people in playing point counterpoint or
pushing back against the things that the
guests say it's more about hearing ideas
from his guests what do the guests think
what are the guests believe what do the
guests want to see happen in politics
and culture and society and today I have
clips for you from an interview he did
with a woman named Brigitte great
Gabriel who is absolutely one of the
most vile right-wing extremists that the
conservative think tank industrial
complex has ever produced in a sort of
less than Dave Rubin like fashion he
actually interring this interview more
of his own ideas and positions into the
conversation for example suggesting that
anti George Soros conspiracy theories
can't be anti-semitic because quote
everything he does is usually against
Israel but I'm sort of getting ahead of
myself here we're not there in this
exploration just yet
I want to focus in on here as we explore
this interview with Brigitte Gabriel is
are the things Brigitte Gabriel is
saying so outrageous that not calling
them out must be denounced when I last
interviewed Dave Rubin I gave him some
examples where I as an interviewer would
come prepared and say hold on a second
that's not right so one example I gave
him is during an interview with David
Horowitz some time ago Horowitz said
Obama is a communist
that's demonstrably untrue it's silly
it's nonsense and I'm not sure what the
format gains by not simply pushing back
against that and saying well what the
hell are you talking about or maybe more
politely can you give some examples of
socialist policy that President Obama
has either proposed or enacted as
president so Dave and I spoke about that
reasonable people can disagree about how
to handle that depending on what you're
trying to get out of the interview but
in this interview that I'm going to play
pieces of for you that Dave Rubin did
with Brigitte Gabriel she repeated the
endlessly debunked conspiracy theory
that George Soros worked with the Nazis
and not only did Dave Rubin not rebut it
he actually appears to agree with it not
once but twice
okay let's start getting into this and
the point of all this is to show first
of all for the people in our audience
not familiar with this program just to
give you an idea of how these interviews
with right-wing extremists go on the
program but also just to think about
whether the positioning of Dave Rubin as
the interviewer who just asked questions
is giving us something of value when the
guest says things as crazy as what
brigitte gabriel said here now in my
book i have a whole section about soros
and i'm funding the media Soros right
now has spent doesn't that make you an
anti-semite if you talk about Soros
that's their new meme so Dave says their
new meme is that talking about Soros is
anti-semitic of course that's not true
right I mean if the idea is to seek
nuance and explore ideas in detail
instead of this cartoonish sort of
black-and-white way we would say you
know talking about Soros
sizing soros is obviously not inherently
anti-semitic but criticizing Soros as a
proxy to portraying Jews as conspiring
to use their ill-gotten riches for the
coordinated control of the political
system or media or whatever well yeah
that's actually part of an anti-semitic
tradition that goes back hundreds of
years and as part of thousands of years
of oppression of Jews but saying the
meme is if you talk about Soros you're
anti-semitic it's pointless it does
absolutely nothing to really generate
debate or any kind of battle of ideas
let's continue I didn't even know he was
Jewish
I'm tell about a year ago does is
usually against Israel stupidity
so again just blistering with logical
fallacies Soros does things against
Israel so therefore criticizing the
criticizers of George Soros cannot
possibly be anti-semitic I mean you
would think he sounds and talks like an
anti-semite much more than me remember
he is the one who worked with the
doctors with the Nazis and actually had
a smile when people asked them how did
you feel about going in and working with
the Nazis against your own people he
said well you know somebody had to do it
so I know I gotta say any problem with
it you know yeah you're not making that
up either no no I mean I watched his
interview because I was very interested
on what makes this man the way he is I
study my enemies okay so actually Rubin
agrees twice here with the Soros worked
with the Nazis thing he says yeah the
first time and then he says you're not
actually you're actually not making that
up the second time that Brigitte Gabriel
keeps talking about this the allowing of
that debunked conspiracy theory to be
recited not only without pushback but
actually agreeing with it is directly
fomenting anti-semitism and what this
relates to is that listen first of all
understand George Soros was born in 1930
okay he was nine when the war broke out
and fourteen when the Nazis surrendered
in 1945 you had to be seventeen to join
the SS so number one there's a picture
that
floats around supposedly of George Soros
in an SS Nazi uniform that literally
could not have been him and it wasn't
it's a guy named Oskar graining that's
number one the next layer of the
conspiracy is okay fine
Soros wasn't in the SS but he was a Nazi
collaborator and Glenn Beck and Alex
Jones and Dinesh D'Souza were involved
in spreading that one and all of this
relates to a sixty minutes interview
that they like to point to which
includes Steve Croft asking George Soros
about whether he was involved in the
confiscation of property from Jews and
there's a moment where George Soros is
completely taken aback by the question
and I encourage you to watch it and it
sort of seems like he said yeah I was
involved in in taking property from Jews
of course we now know the truth of this
and later in the interview George Soros
makes it clear that he doesn't regret
anything he did because he didn't do
anything he saw this happening and what
happened was that George Soros had a
caretaker during World War two who was
forced by the Nazis to inventory to make
lists of properties that the Nazis
seized from Jews one time George Soros
went with that guy when that guy was
taking inventory of properties okay
that's what happened and to allow or
even agree with the perpetuation of that
conspiracy theory is absolutely and
totally disgusting and then it becomes
truly dangerous literally pushing
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
then Brigitte Gabriel goes further
pushing the idea that Soros personally
approves the talking points of media
this is the conspiracy theory that
Jewish rich dudes tell the media what to
say take a look this is exactly how we
end up with reporters who are no longer
reporters they are activists with a
national platform media platform who get
on television every night and basically
spew
same [ __ ] political points approved
by syrups and they all say the same
thing whether it's a Huffington Post the
New York Times The Associated Press
Reuters MSNBC CNBC ABC the same buzzword
and it's all coordinated
I actually saw some comments about this
on our YouTube channel there was a day
last week where my commentary about
something related to immigration was
similar to the commentary on The Young
Turks and people were saying Soros is
dictating the talking points David
Pakman and the Young Turks are both
getting their talking points from the
same people obviously this is insane
I've never had any contact with Soros I
don't watch The Young Turks I just don't
have time to watch any other shows it
might just be that a story came up and
multiple media outlets came to the same
conclusion battle of ideas right these
are the ideas that were presented by
Brigitte Gabriel and they were not even
remotely opposed then lastly and this is
just I mean that the the lowest of the
low Brigitte Gabriel compares herself to
Anne Frank I don't even know that this
part requires analysis see I am the Anne
Frank who lived to tell about it can you
imagine if Anne Frank was alive and the
Nazis were spreading worldwide and she
just escaped the concentration camps and
she came to the United States and Nazism
started rising in the United States she
would be saying the same words that she
said when she was alive and with my in
my case I started speaking after the
attacks on 9/11 on the United States I
started speaking about the threat of
radical Islam to world peace in our
national security
this part is merely delusional I mean
there's just no way in which Brigitte
Gabriel is like Anne Frank I actually
recently reread Anne Frank's diary and
I'm seeing a bit of a gap between Anne
Frank and Brigitte Gabriel so let's see
if we can categorize this a little bit
interviewing conservatives like David
Brooks or Thomas solo and hearing out
their ideas that's quite reasonable for
an interview show like this one I have
no problem with that at all bringing on
people like James d'amour from the
Google memo or this guy named Karl
Benjamin he goes by Sargon on the
internet that's starting to get sort of
fringe but it's like okay if you
want to push back about about what they
say fine it's kind of dumb but don't
push back against it when you start
bringing people on like stefan molyneux
and brigitte gabriel first of all as if
they even have big ideas to present to
us right they just spout this nonsense
unopposed these are extremists radicals
I have no problem with them being
interviewed I interview extremists but
it needs to be responsible platforming
and likewise I used to have an invite to
do Dave Rubens show I don't know if that
invite is still open at this point I
don't know if it were and I did that
show I would expect to be challenged on
my views I would not assume that I can
show up and just say whatever I want
with no critical a critical analysis
happening as it's taking place in real
time it's more a question of whether
Dave Rubin feels ok doing an interview
with someone like Brigitte Gabriel in
this way how does he rationalize
handling it in this way privately I get
how you do it publicly but I don't know
how I'd live with myself privately if I
did interviews in this way it's like if
I had Richard Spencer on and I said oh
how interesting novel and fascinating
new ideas great I couldn't do something
like that I couldn't live with myself I
also don't really understand why Rubens
funders like learn liberty the more
libertarian minded folks I don't even
know how they are ok with Brigitte
Gabriel being allowed to come on insite
unsubstantiated debunked anti-semitic
talking points with no challenge like I
don't even know how that helps their
brand in their partnership but that's
not really my business that's for them
to figure out absolutely and completely
off the rails send me your thoughts were
on Instagram at David Pakman show
quick break back after this I have a
special treat for you today and it's of
the tables being turned on the bully as
many of you know I relish and thrive on
social awkwardness and yesterday we had
it in droves on the national stage and
we're gonna look at it together today
and when I save the tables were turned
on the
I mean of course Donald Trump Donald
Trump who bullies everyone on Twitter in
person threatening people with prison
making fun of their disabilities making
fun of their appearance threatening them
with getting them fired all of that
stuff he's the quintessential bully the
tables were very much turned yesterday
at George HW Bush's funeral at the
National Cathedral in DC I was sort of
watching this off and on as I prepared
yesterday's show and at one point Donald
Trump seemed to be sleeping which we'll
get to later but at all times Donald
Trump looked completely miserable
because he was the odd one out among
adults quite frankly he was the loser
Bayda not respected or even acknowledged
by some of the people that were there
and when Donald Trump first walked in he
walked over to where all of the
presidents were sitting and President
Obama very graciously greeting Melania
Trump Donald Trump immediately sort of
unsure how to handle himself and he
shakes Barack Obama's hand and Barack
Obama sort of looks lukewarm Michelle
Obama straight-up looks disgusted with
him and then the Clintons don't even
look over or move Bill and Hillary
Clinton look like statues as Donald
Trump enters the Carters don't even care
about Trump one way or the other they're
checking their watches and looking at
the program they're not even considering
interrupting what they're doing to greet
Donald Trump and it was delightfully
awkward and why should they be nice to
Trump this goes beyond common courtesy
right Trump was the leader of the
birther movement against Barack Obama
and slams him daily Trump said Hillary
Clinton should be in prison and
considered directing the Justice
Department to prosecute her
he's called Jimmy Carter the second
worst president ever behind Barack Obama
so what I say Pat is good for them Trump
looked just as miserable there as he did
in Argentina among world leaders who act
like adults and simply don't see Donald
Trump as an adult that they're at their
level I say good for them because
they're doing what the rest of the world
is increasingly doing which is they see
Trump as a joke as a sort of
inconvenience that is there
plain and simple if there's anyone else
I would sort of feel bad it's like this
person's not being part of the community
he's not let in in the club but Donald
Trump deserves it so I don't feel bad at
all
he was only even at George HW Bush's
funeral because George HW Bush said I
want Trump there in the interests of
sort of unity and moving beyond
political disagreements that that we've
had but do you think that the other
people there want him there this is some
of the best video I've seen in a long
time and if we can put it back up what
once more Pat just to look at it again
pay particular attention not just to the
looks on the presidents and wives and
spouses faces but look at how Donald
Trump just looks miserable to be there
no I guess I have to say I even Dick
Cheney looking at him like what species
are you my friend I think that this is
exactly exactly how he should be treated
and I know that there were people who
will say it's childish for the Clintons
and the Carters and the Obamas to treat
Trump in this way no what's childish is
what Donald Trump has been doing for
three to four years at this point that's
actually what's embarrassing and it's
Trump and his followers who should be
embarrassed not the Clintons not the
Carters and certainly not the Obamas who
have been more than gracious to this guy
despite his disgusting behavior